[موسيقى]
في اكبر هجوم منذ اسابيع نحو 80 صاروخا
روسيا بعيدا المدى ومسيرات مفخخه استهدفت
مناطق واسعه في اوكرانيا
منخار كيف شرقا الى ليفيف غربا وصولا الى
خرسون في الجنوب اردن كما تقول موسكو على
الهجمات التي تعرضت لها موقع توب بريانسكا
الروسيه قبل نحو اسبوع تقول القوات
الاوكرانيه انها اسقطت 34 صاروخا واربع
مسيرات ايرانيه الصنع اطلقت من عمق
الاراضي الروسيه ومن اسطول موسكو في البحر
الاسود واستهدفت كامل الاراضي الاوكرانيه
بحسب السلطات المحليه في كييف فان الضربات
الصاروخيه استهدفت البنيه التحتيه ما ادى
الى حرمان 40% من السكان من التدفئه
في الشمال الشرقي ضرب خمسه عشر صاروخا
البنيه التحتيه في خارقين ما ادى الى
انقطاع الكهرباء بشكل شبه كامل عن المدينه
اما في الغرب وتحديدا في ليفيذ فقد تحدثت
السلطات عن مقتل خمسه اشخاص في القصف
الصاروخي الذي استهدف المدينه
جنوبا استهدف القصف مولدات الطاقه في
اوديسا كما اسفر عن مقتل مدنيين في خرسون
حسب الرئاسه الاوكرانيه وزير الطاقه
الاوكراني اكد ان الخط الاخير الذي يغذي
محطه النوويه جنوب شرقي البلاد تضرر نتيجه
القصف الروسي وتسبب بانقطاع امدادات
الكهرباء عن المحطه وانها تعمل حاليا على
مولدات الديزل لكن سلطات المواليه لروسيا
اعتبرت تلك التصريحات مجرد استفزاز
في موسكو اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان الهجمه الصاروخيه جاءت انتقاما
وردا على ما وصفها بالهجمات الارهابيه
التي تعرضت لها مقاطعه بريانس الاسبوع
الماضي على يد مجموعه اوكرانيه نجحت في
التسلل اليها
واكدت روسيا ان هجماتها الصاروخيه دمرت
مواقع اوكرانيه للمسيرات واحبطت عمليات
لنقل اسلحه الى اوكرانيا مؤكده استخدام
صواريخ كينجال الفرد صوتيه